more and more people are realizing that
these letters have nothing to do with
each other I want to show you this this
is Andrew Tate talking about how
LGBT makes absolutely no sense
lgbtq they package it all together and I
would argue that G and T are very
different things a gay man and someone
who's chopped the dick off are very
different things so they package it all
together so now cut the spectrum of your
enemy is so large you have people who
are complete fully this way if you have
people who we accept that are normal in
society we have no problem with gay
people and they put it all together
you're an enemy of all these people and
they complicate the argument and they
mix it all together and I draw bigot and
really you just want your kids to be
left alone yeah
yeah that's right and that's what most
people have come around to again you
don't have to love gay people you should
you should like people based on their
behaviors and you know whatever you
don't have to right again you can have
your own religious beliefs you can't
legislate those beliefs but he got it
right there they have widened the
spectrum of these things because the
gays and the lesbians it was all taken
care of you got marriage no law is
discriminating against everybody you got
equality but the activists could not
give it up because they need division
the non-profits need division Joy Reed
needs division all of these people need
that division because without the
division you might just go ahead and
live your life and be happy and not give
them money and not give them attention
and they don't deserve either one of
those things so this is exactly why
there is so much division right now
because woke the most it is the most
dangerous ideology that we have had in
America in the last 50 years it's
communism on steroids right it's
collectivism with a dash of racism and
gender confusion and once you are
whittled down to your inherent
differences you are going to have a very
difficult Society to operate in because
especially in America where we've
welcomed everybody
foreign
[Music]